ludovic de l'air je vous êtes expert en
communication alors justement une
question une campagne pour le second
tour
uniquement sur les réseaux sociaux et
dans les médias est ce que cela a pu
jouer comme mode de campagne selon vous
bah en fait ça signifie surtout que
c'était pas une campagne
donc on est très loin d'une élection on
est dans la continuité d'un président
qui impose sa volonté à 66 millions
française qu'il ait été choisi par 8,6
d'entre eux donc là on n'appelle pas ça
la démocratie
c'est une élection c'est la source de la
légitimité pour un élu ce qui fait que
les représentants du peuple qui l'a élu
là aujourd'hui on à 60% d'abstention
donc c'est la fin non seulement les
partis traditionnels mais même de la
vème république
enfin faut qu'on arrête ça ne s'arrête
plus à rien il ya des gens qui sont
exprimées depuis trois ans dans la rue
qui ont même été de matraques et pour ça
on leur a tiré dessus et aujourd'hui
n'ont pas été voter parce qu'en fait ils
ne sont pas écoutés ne sont pas
entendues donc c'est un désaveu complet
de la classe politique qui a joué pour
vous que ce n'est pas la crise qui a
joué justement sur cette abstention
mais on a tous vu des quais de seine
depuis quinze jours les gens sont dehors
donc on va pas me dire que là c'est la
peur du virus qui infecte les gens pas
été votée c'était gens ont le sentiment
de pas et écouter la convention sitting
sur le climat est déjà un camouflet
parce que ils sont déjà repoussé dans
leurs 22 par edouard philippe et par
emmanuel macron il avait gardé sous le
coude pour demain donc là évidemment
comme il ya un signal fort qu'il a enfin
entendu parce qu'en fait l'écologie en
france a fait des années ça préoccupe
beaucoup de monde ça fait des années que
des mouvements le clame haut et fort et
même au local donc donc donc c'est une
découverte ce soir pour l'éditorialiste
de deux de ses huit et de bfm et pour
notre président mais en fait ça fait
longtemps qu'on compte c'est que
l'écologie est un sujet qui préoccupe
les gens et puis surtout lors du coup on
a une merveilleuse percée d'europe
écologie les verts et ses alliés et
l'important dans la france et ses alliés
et j'espère qu'il vaut mieux se
comporter que la façon qu'on dise qu'on
porte au parlement européen qui vont
respecter leur parole les programmes
donc là on rentre dans une phase qui
comme très très très complexe et très
chahuté parce que 60% d'abstention ce
n'est plus une élection dont un premier
tour fantoche en second tour fantoche
c'est quand même très compliqué en
termes de légitimité
mes félicitations évidemment tous ceux
qui ont été élus personnellement je
félicite l'équipe de lyon s'est pas
faite auprès d'eux
vide et je suis très content leur
victoire et à l'équipe de lauzès que je
rejoins la fin de semaine
petit village qui a monté une liste
citoyenne mais mais mais hormis les
féliciter et un vrai problème
démocratique c'est 60% aux imagine fort
n'a jamais à tort a atteint sa et non on
ne peut pas dire que celle commise
il faut arrêter les bêtises les rues
sont pleines et bars sont pleins les
restaurants sont pleins
donc on va pas dire qu'elle est parisien
par exemple injecter cette semaine à
paris donc je ne peux parler que de
paris mais on ne peut pas dire que les
parisiens n'ont pas été votées par peur
du virus
non ils n'ont pas été voter parce que
c'est surtout les classes populaires qui
n'ont pas été votées en et grandes
villes donc des gens qui ne s'interprète
qu'il se sent pas écouté même s'ils vont
risquer leur vie dans la rue tous les
week-ends à se faire tirer dessus par la
police donc donc ces gens là n'ont pas
été voter c'est un signal extrêmement
important que notre démocratie ne
fonctionne plus il faut absolument
réformer rénover notre démocratie et
redonner la parole aux citoyens les
listes citoyenne qui gagne c'est un très
très bon signal il va falloir respecter
cette parole parce que si on fait des
déçus dans les grandes villes sur lequel
les citoyennes sont arrivés en tête ont
pas déclencher un mouvement et un retour
de bâton qui sera d'autant plus violent
on est à un moment capital de notre
jeune démocratie
emmanuel macron a réagi ce soir il dit
qu'il va apporter des restes des
réponses fortes à sa convention pour le
climat c'est une manière de répondre
aussi à cette percée des verts
aujourd'hui et et à cette défaite
globale depuis le premier tour en tout
cas pour la république en marche moi
j'ai travaillé assez proche de cette
convention pour le climat depuis un an
et demi
en fait il cherche à la faire taire
depuis un an et demi un joli très
sincèrement parce qu'il est évident les
mesures ne l'intéressent pas et
contredit complètement sa politique donc
il va apporter des réponses fortes comme
il le fait depuis deux ans c'est à dire
rien on va encore brasser du vent
on verra on voir des gens déçus et je
pense que ces réunions de travail
remarquable qu'il a fait avec cette
convention a amené à un programme
extrêmement 100 c est ce qui sort de la
convention climat est admirable vraiment
c'est admirable c'est d'ailleurs
compatible avec un stand de programme
qui devait présenter à la présidentielle
en tout cas un mais mais là on va voir
ce qu'il va apporter demain mais on
connaît par coeur maintenant on n'écoute
même plus on n'écoute même plus il ya
qu'à voir ses scores d'audience quand il
parle à la télé on va même pu voter dans
safran sentira bien après macro
avant et après macron hills et promis
république rétabli une république
exemplaire et un barrage contre le front
national
grâce à lui le front national à une
première grande ville en france c'est
historique et on n'a jamais eu autant de
records d'abstention en france
dire qu'il a réussi à désintéresser à
dégoûter tous les français de la
politique alors qu'on a des millions de
personnes dans la rue toutes les
semaines
donc il arrive un tour de force on verra
ce qu'il va faire demain je me tourne
vers vous à présent vous êtes expert en
communication on a eu une campagne assez
atypique trois semaines c'est long trois
semaines sans pouvoir d'ailleurs avoir
de contact vraiment proche avec la
population est-ce que ça a faussé selon
vous les résultats
fayçal et pense qu'on entend parfois
aussi les résultats en fait on a gagné
là ce qu'on entend depuis tout à l'heure
et j'ai eu plusieurs chaînes allumé un
côté cédé interprétation nationale de ce
qui s'est passé il sera au plan local
quand christian jacob dit on renoue avec
la victoire en fait saillant toujours
rien compris
dire que ça que je suis désolé de le
marteler on à 60% d'abstention c'est une
catastrophe non démocratiques vraiment
c'est une catastrophe ce n'est pas une
donnée comptable c'est une catastrophe
et on a quand même une campagne qui n'a
pas eu lieu
donc des pouvoirs publics qui ont refusé
lmh réponse claire serre que les
pouvoirs publics ont refusé de faire une
élection digne légitime crédible et on a
une réponse qui est 60% d'abstention
donc une n'y a pas eu de campagne le
temps une campagne c'est le temps de la
conviction d'échangés autour de projets
c'est pas le temps on affiche des têtes
sur des affiches et les gens votent un
peu comme ils peuvent et en fonction des
idées vagues idées qu'ils ont des
mouvements qui 1
et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que la
plupart des candidats en marche ce
n'était même pas étiquetés en marche et
malgré ça ils ont pris une branlée
donc ils s'étaient pas une campagne une
campagne c'est un truc important en fait
ce sont des projets écrit par des gens
qui vont convaincre et écouter pour
pouvoir même les modifiés pendant leur
pratique du pouvoir et le le voc qui en
résultent conférer une légitimité
démocratique qui fait que nous français
citoyen nous donnons notre argent et
nous laissons la décision qui nous
incombe parce que la démocratie la
république c'est le gouvernement du
peuple par le peuple pour le peuple et
pas pour les intérêts privés
donc là on n'a aucune des données qui ne
générait qui réunit apple
n'y a pas eu de temps de conviction
réelle hormis par les réseaux sociaux
c'est là qu'en fait la campagne est
soumise aux algorithmes le facebook
s'efface c'est indigne
c'est indigne on ne peut pas admettre
qu'un choix démocratique a été fait en
fonction des algorithmes de facebook ça
n'est pas bon ou de twitter ça n'est pas
possible donc on a une réponse claire
c'est que les gens n'ont pas été votés
il va voir tirer des conclusions mais
des conclusions nationales
on ne peut pas élection après élection
martelé qu'il ya de plus en plus
abstentions il ne rien faire et ne pas
laisser les gens s'exprimer quand il
veut quand il souhaite le faire par
exemple référendum d'initiative
citoyenne
c'est la réponse parfaite à au score
d'abstention qu'on a là ce qu'on a des
gens qui nous disent on veut avoir plus
souvent la parole et pouvoir dire aux
gens qui dévouent leurs paroles qui ne
restent pas respectent pas leurs
engagements qu'on se passe 2 est bien là
on aura une réponse très claire
faisons un référendum demain sur le sur
le rich et on verra ce que ça va donner
en termes de taux de participation
là les gens n'étaient pas vraiment
concernés par la question qui leur était
posée il ya malgré tout des tendances
qui se dégagent
je voulais quand même ajouté un point si
vous me permettez magali il faut
vraiment connaître année yannick dago le
travail de sape qu'elle fait depuis des
années pour expliquer qu'une mairie un
rôle à jouer par rapport au
réchauffement climatique global
pour ça les récompenser ce qu'elle est
réélu aussi parce que la campagne était
pitoyable entre dati griveaux et bu un
bon il ya quand même une voie royale
mais aussi elle a quand même implanté
c'est cette idée dans un certain nombre
de grandes agglomérations et le travail
qui est fait le travail de sape
permanent qui est fait sur il ya des
bouchons la rue de rivoli du praticable
en voiture et c est bien là on voit que
oui c'est un travail qu'il faut mener et
pour ça il faut quand même féliciter
anne hidalgo me tourne vers vous les
d'olic de leers justement sur cette
résurgence on va dire en tout cas de la
gauche comment est-ce que vous
l'analysez est ce que c'est le social
qui prend le dessus alors qu'on est en
crise économique après la crise
sanitaire au vent c'est en fait il ya
plusieurs données vous savez c'est que
bon vous savez le temps ce qu'on entend
par la gauche il ya des alliances qui
ont été faites mais qui sont pas des
alliances d'étiquettes et résilience re
défaite sur les programmes des sciences
qui ont été faites sur des contenus et
ça c'est très important
donc il va falloir et le travail
d'années doit être faite sur le travail
de ces municipalités maintenant le sort
si vous respectez ces programmes parce
que une fois y avoir de bleu
hesdin lyons qu'autour de projet il faut
arrêter de parler des personnes il
faudrait que parler nous parler des
étiquettes
7 / personnalisation de la vie politique
est néfaste à la démocratie il faut
parler de projet de projet de société
aujourd'hui le bilan de ces municipales
c'est que les électeurs n'ont pas fait
société et l'important c'est de faire
société
donc il faut parler de projets de
contenus il ya effectivement une lame de
fond mais depuis des années qui est
réprimée par par beaucoup de mouvements
qui est qui et l'écologie et surtout
l'humanisme solidaire et sociale et ça
c'est un socle sur lequel il faut
s'appuyer évidemment mais sur des
programmes et donc il va pas falloir à
nouveau pérorer sur des alliances refusé
parce qu'on a en face de nous des gens
qui sont affichés parce que là tout le
monde va se repeindre en vert on va voir
des petits bonhommes cetelem absolument
partout et pour autant personne ne parle
vraiment d'écologie il ya un instant et
yannick jadot qui savaient qu'ils
s'expriment et à colombes dans une
espèce de parodie de son élection 2022
qui dont il rêve déjà
non il faut parler de projet le contenu
et de vraies préoccupations et de
mesures concrètes à mettre en place
quand je vois la mairie de bordeaux qui
est gagné sans gratuité des services
publics avec des propositions qui sont
les propositions à nouveau sibylline et
de la novlangue
c'est inquiétant c'est inquiétant donc
il faut constituer chez complètement
d'accord avec ndiaga diop
il faut constituer absolument débloquer
des alliances autour de projets concrets
et pas autour d'individus ou
d'étiquettes les étiquettes n'ont aucun
sens les et kate ne sert qu'à rassembler
sur des projets de contenus qui sont
écrit collectivement c'est une vague
citoyenne qui s'est exprimée par par son
refus de voter et ceux qui sont votées
par l'accession à la mairie de liste
citoyenne
c'est une première en france dont il
faut absolument pousser ses listes
citoyenne créé des process politique
autour
et surtout arrêter de communiquer sur
les individus il faut sortir de ce
schéma là mais y compris médiatiquement
il faut absolument qu'on sait qu'on ce
concept con qu'on s'abstienne de
personnaliser de cette façon dans la vie
politique il faut remettre sur le débat
avec les français des mesures et des
projets de société
quelle société automne comment peut-on
vivre ensemble c'est ça qui compte et
qui est important et comment on répond
aux granges
ce qui nous dépasse nationalement les
grands enjeux internationaux qui sont
leur distribution et l'écologie merci a
voulu de ludovic de la recherche je
rappelle que vous êtes expert en
communication